THE WORST ADVICE IN MARCH.
ACCORDING TO THE MOB, THE
PRESIDENT DESERVES NO CREDIT AT
ALL.
HERE FROM THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION, HE KNOWS THE
PRESIDENT PRETTY WELL, HE GREW
UP WITH HIM, DONALD TRUMP JR.
>> I’M DOING WELL, HOW ABOUT
YOURSELF?
>> Sean: I USED TO SAY IF YOUR
DAD CURED CANCER THEY WOULDN’T
GIVE HIM CREDIT.
NOW I THINK I’VE BEEN KIND OF
PROVEN RIGHT BECAUSE THERE’S
NEVER BEEN A MEDICAL
MOBILIZATION LIKE THAT, THEY
CAN’T ADMIT ANYTHING THAT HE’S
DONE WELL.
NEW YORK WOULD BE DEAD WITHOUT
DONALD TRUMP’S HELP, PERIOD.
>> I AGREE AND THE REVISIONIST
HISTORY ON EVERYTHING AS YOU
POINTED OUT SO WELL IS WELL IS
INSANE.
THE SAME PEOPLE ARE SAYING HE
DIDN’T ACT OR THE SAME PEOPLE
ARE SAYING HE STOPPED THE
FLIGHTS FROM WUHAN CHINA,
STOPPING THE FLIGHTS FROM THE
EPICENTER OF THIS OUTBREAK, THEY
SAID IT WAS TOO AGGRESSIVE, IT
WAS XENOPHOBIC, IT WAS RACIST
THAT IT WAS TOO MUCH.
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO
DO THIS, THEY HAD STATISTICS,
2 MILLION AMERICANS WERE GOING
TO DIE.
WE ARE AT ONE 40TH OF THAT, NOT
ONE OF THOSE IS ACCEPTABLE BUT
THAT’S A PRETTY GOOD RESPONSE
CONSIDERING WHAT THEY SAID WE
WERE UP AGAINST AND IT’S BECAUSE
HE’S GOTTEN THINGS DONE.
HE’S WORKED WELL WITH THE TEAM
WHO HAVE ACTED AGGRESSIVELY,
WITH MADE UP DECISIONS LIKE
SHUTTING DOWN TRAVEL FROM
ANOTHER COUNTRY WHEN EVERYONE
SAID IT WAS XENOPHOBIC AND
RACIST.
EVERYTHING IS RACIST THAT
DONALD TRUMP DOES, THAT’S ALL
THEY HAVE LEFT ON THE OTHER SIDE
SIDE.
IT’S DISGUSTING WATCHING THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO WERE LITERALLY
OUTRAGED TWO MONTHS AGO ABOUT
THE ACTIONS THAT HE TOOK, THE
CALLS TO PREVENT THE SPREAD
COMING INTO THIS COUNTRY, NOW
THEY ARE OUTRAGED AND THEY’RE
ABLE TO SPIN THIS REVISIONIST
HISTORY AS THOUGH IT’S FACT.
IT’S A NEW LOW FOR THE MEDIA AND
THEY HAVE A LOT OF LOWS IN THE
LAST FOUR YEARS.
>> Sean: I HAVE ASKED YOUR DAD
IN AN INTERVIEW WHY WITH TEN
DAYS AFTER THE FIRST CASE
IDENTIFIED IN THE COUNTRY -- HE
TOOK A LOT OF TO THAT.
>> IT WASN’T AN EASY DECISION TO
MAKE.
>> Sean: PRETTY INSIGHTFUL.
THE PERSON WHO WON THE COUNTRY
THE MOST ABOUT CHINA WAS YOUR
FATHER, THE PERSON WHO WARNED
THE MOST ABOUT BOARDERS WAS YOUR
FATHER, YOU THINK THERE WILL BE
ISSUES AND 194 DAYS?
>> IF THERE’S ONE THING THAT THE
CORONAVIRUS HAS TAUGHT US IT’S
THAT DONALD TRUMP AND HIS AGENDA
IN 2016 WAS 100% RIGHT.
WE DO NEED TO CONTROL OUR SUPPLY
CHAINS, WE DO NEED TO HAVE
AMERICAN MANUFACTURING SO THE
CHINESE CAN DO WHAT THEY DID AND
BASICALLY SAY YOU’RE NOT BUYING
INTO WAR PROPAGANDA, OUR TALKING
POINTS, YOU’RE CRITICIZING US
FOR ALLOWING THIS PLAGUE TO
SPREAD THE WAY IT DID?
WE MAY CUT OFF THE ANTIBIOTICS
THAT ARE DESIGNED MADE BY YOUR
COMPANY’S BUT WE CONTROL THEM,
SO YOU’RE NOT GETTING THEM.
WE CAN’T ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
LOOK HOW QUICK MEXICO SHUT DOWN
THE BORDER TO THE U.S. -- THEY
SAID IT CAN ACTUALLY BE DONE.
IF THERE’S ONE THING THIS HAS
SHOWN US IT’S THAT DONALD TRUMP
WAS RIGHT ALL ALONG.
HE’S THE GUY THAT GOT IT AND SAW
THAT, HE ALSO BUILT THE GREATEST
ECONOMY AMERICA HAS EVER KNOWN,
HE’S THE GUY THAT CAN MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN AGAIN ONCE
WE GET THROUGH THIS.
HUNTER BIDEN’S SON TOOK
1.5 MILLION FROM THE CHINESE AND
HE’S ON THE RECORD SAYING CHINA
IS OUR FRIEND.
>> Sean: I HAVE
SECRETARY POMPEO STANDING BY BUT